It's quick, but the reason I'm talking about who's above you
is the baron.
Located near the border, on the outskirts of town
Commercial support The
content is definitely about the hero
Yes,
why do you know the birth of the
hero?
Why did the young man agree that there was a prophecy that that child was a hero? The
gender and hair color match, and he is strong.In
addition, the patient who was sent to the school last year has disappeared together with the patient.
Crane is a
hero It's been
spread among informants I wonder if
this is enough Thank you very much Thanks to you, I understand what I wanted to know Well
done Enlightenment It's a
reward You can eat it
[Music]